Batman vs Superman is an all-consuming
cultural behemoth the purest incarnation
of the tentpole film possibly the last
superhero movie of any real cultural
importance at least for the next 15 to
20 years until the whole genres
inevitably resurrected after it's
equally inevitable death Batman vs
Superman is inescapable a quarter of a
billion dollars poured just into
production with at least another quarter
billion spent on marketing and all its
flavors in many ways Batman vs Superman
is pristine perfect even the
preservation of screen Direction is
flawless the continuity of action
meticulous multiple people were employed
with the sole job of making sure henry
cavill sneer was just a right every
takes so that it would cut together
without issue
the computer-generated elements are so
flawlessly photorealistic that you'd be
forgiven for not noticing that there's
more live-action cinema in wall-e it is
an expertly sculpted puff of air a dour
exhausting 150 minute ode to create a
bankruptcy Batman vs Superman is the
kind of movie that makes you question
your faith in cinema itself why did we
ever care on some levels its existence
functions as a commentary on the nature
of audience is this not what we signed
up for a high-mass where we
ritualistically recount the exploits of
untouchable demigods in a detached
language intentionally posturing itself
above the supplicants in the pews in the
beginning there was darkness and then
Joe Chill shot Thomas and Martha Wayne
let us pray you may have gathered this
already but I didn't much care for
Batman vs Superman though like I said in
many ways the film is perfect it
polished and buffed to a rooting shine
it is technically flawless in the way
that only a quarter of a billion dollars
can buy the script is trash of course a
trifling joyless tour through plot
cul-de-sacs and actions the characters
take or fail to take for no internal
reason other than to progress the meager
play
this sounds damning but in truth it
describes far more films than it
excludes it's true failing is spiritual
it is an empty vessel
it is a vast revival tent with nothing
inside meta and chicken is the opposite
of a cultural behemoth it is also a
deeply flawed film a Danish absurdist
comedy there is a good chance that
you've never heard of it and an even
better chance that you'll never see it
or even possibly have a chance to see it
Mads Mikkelsen rapes a bunch of chickens
that's not even a terribly important
point to the overall structure of the
film but it gets your attention the lure
is a Polish electro-pop strip club
musical adaptation of the Little Mermaid
nuts is a documentary about the history
of medical quackery told mostly through
the lens of a quack doctor self
mythologizing biography it is as much
about quack medicine and cure-alls as it
is about the way that we as an audience
interact with the authority of
authorship lace crater is a mumblecore
horror about a woman who catches an STD
from a ghost
the matically it's about the
unpredictability of existence and the
lack of a storybook arc to our lives
under the shadow is an Iranian horror
film about the way that our context
shapes and confines us this isn't to say
that there are some inherently noble
dimension to films that succeed it's
simply not being Batman vs Superman even
Indy underground films are still
products made by creators who are
generally aware of the context that they
exist in whether you are lace crater or
Batman vs. Superman you still need to
address fundamental questions of appeal
of audience of marketing the key
differences in the answers to these
questions the sense of scope and scale
where Snyder and friends come up with a
solution of throwing a quarter billion
dollars of advertising at the problem
meaner artists rely on taboo gimmick in
the hook looma quarterly a local online
arts magazine commissioned me to create
a video essay about the calgary
underground Film Festival the topic was
left to me to decide however broad or
specific I wanted to make it whether I
wanted to talk about something only
broadly tangental to the idea of the
festival or if I wanted to drill down
deep into the specifics of any one film
that I saw I was given a press pass a
collection of trailer stubs and left to
run amok I mention this because it's the
critical context through which I
experienced the festival it is the
context that this
ese exists within it is the product of a
process where I have been asked to make
something and within that space I am now
confronted with a number of questions I
would most certainly like to make
something that I am personally
comfortable attaching my name to and to
make something that the editors at luma
will feel reflects the tone and depth
that they want for the publication I
would like to make something that my
regular audience would engage with and
share I want to take the opportunity to
push myself stepping outside the
boundaries of the work I traditionally
produce but not so far that I end up in
unfamiliar territory I am pulled between
the competing desire to produce
something novel and risky but also safe
familiar and appealing I lurked around
the festival edges for days I
interviewed several of the creators
involved with cuff Cade an arcade-style
edition of indie games - the festival as
a symbiotic attempt at broadening the
umbrella of art that the festival
promotes and giving the public more ways
to engage with the space one of the
creators is a woman whom I've had
several exchanges with before on Twitter
none of which were terribly polite on
anyone's part the backstory behind the
interactions are so petty and obtuse
that it would take an entire essay just
to explain and the stakes are so low
that you're relevant feels like too soft
a description nonetheless the anxiety of
that interaction hovered over me for
days the interview itself was
lightweight and cordial little more than
an opportunity for self-promotion after
publishing an edit of the interviews I
reflected on the puff-piece nature of it
and vowed to come back to the subject
later in the week to try and get a
meteor bite at the idea of games as
independent art I wanted to come back
and talk about the way that we interface
games with the public the performative
aspects of arcades as gaming in the
public space and how that context
changes the way the creators think about
their own work I never did come back to
it I took the opportunity afforded by
the privilege of a press pass to
interview several of the festival
programmers and volunteers they were
good interviews but what is there to say
really
cuff is a somewhat self-explanatory
thing an opportunity to throw a party
promote some niche works have some fun
and make a few bucks
there are worse reasons to do things and
there's not a lot of hard questions to
ask this is a dimension that has always
haunted my attempts to say something
about festivals and conventions they are
commercial ventures in a nice ecosystem
a chance for self-promotion a chance to
share something silly
with an audience looking to get off the
beaten path but it is ultimately
mitigated risk it is delivering a
desired product to a willing audience it
is an act of Commerce not an act of
rebellion underground to me means
shining a spotlight on films that might
not otherwise get to be seen so I see us
as a festival that is specifically
curated to select films that might not
otherwise get a wider release with a few
selections that will bring the crowds
this is the context that the festival
itself exists in asking the same
questions what kind of a product do you
want to make and attach your name to how
do you balance the pressures of novelty
and the pressures of appeal the week
culminated in taking Harrison Atkins the
writer director and editor of lace
crater out to breakfast and recording an
hour-long interview but the philosophy
of filmmaking well we ate waffles and
omelets I wanted to talk about the
maturing of mumblecore in the sense of
generational anxiety that I've always
felt lies at the root of the sub-genre
mumblecore is an expression of
millennial angst our crack at cinema
verite our attempt at capturing
something authentic and real there I
think mumblecore corresponds both to
like it to like a a like a simple like
pragmatic sensibility and also like this
like this ethos that's sort of
interested in like a more
naturalistic or emotionally like
truthful like random storytelling the
version of this essay built around that
idea never materialized I began to write
it but quickly self edited it into
oblivion it wasn't good enough
my research wasn't complete enough my
familiarity not comfortable enough it
was stale I threw it out because the
anxiety at the core of my self
assignment was to try and capture
something more than just a puff piece
promoting a local arts festival men and
chickens stars mads mikkelsen because
without the brand power of the name
actor the film would never have been
made deep down I know I'm not giving
cuff enough credit
maybe I'm undermining myself due to my
own perceived deficiencies I want to tap
into something deeper than the surface
some ephemeral real that is beyond
simple commercialism some active
rebellion and in that I blind myself to
what's actually there I don't want to
perceive myself as the puff piece writer
and that makes me dismissive of things
that are easy to explain this is a flaw
my desk is littered with Dr Pepper cans
promoting Batman vs Superman Jesse
Eisenberg's Lex Luthor stares at me from
the side of a dozen empty cans that I
haven't bothered to move to the
recycling bin I keep not six feet away
cuffs sell swag arranges deals with
sponsors and promoters the booze flows
and the concession is cash only the
subversive the offbeat the flawed the
undesirable these are the products and
they are for sale in the context of
capitalism is there any act of rebellion
or is it all just making the machines of
Commerce work in favor of your interests
Batman vs Superman spent a quarter of a
billion dollars to fill my peripheral
vision with endless reminders of the
other quarter of a billion dollars spent
making a vapid pay into the idea of the
audience's willing idiots honestly I had
started to believe it the simplicity of
cuff the fact that film festivals aren't
some unique synthesis of elements
creating some new thing greater than the
sum of its parts isn't important cuff
may be self-explanatory it may be
exactly what it says on the tin that may
very well be a strength there may not be
deeper questions to ask about the
metaphysical idea of an underground Film
Festival because all the important stuff
is right there laid out front it is a
party where movie fans
bring in some weird stuff for other fans
of weird stuff it's that simple and
that's enough underground film is not
some strange unknowable thing its movies
its films made with passion those made
with cynicism those made with
aspirations for greatness and films made
out of lazy and nurse'
there is no mystical quality that is
imbued into a film by virtue of being
underground in many ways you could say
that underground films aren't even
special the difference between
mainstream and underground is largely
semantic anyway independent underground
films are still just films it is an
industry with an audience that question
which is kind of like the commercial
question has become so much more like
for granted for me and like the wake of
lace banner and it was like while I was
making because now you've got a product
that will do you so do you like what I
do well that's the thing it's like when
I was making the movie I wasn't thinking
about selling movie I was thinking about
like making something that like adhere
to like the movie that I saw in my head
I wasn't thinking about like whether
that movie that I saw in my head was
something that you know like a company
could like come and make money on by
like exploiting
you know and I think you know I don't
think lace Gators like uncommercial I
think I think like there's a lot about
it that like hooks audiences in that
like art there it's a little bit high
concept which i think is a cool trait
for trying to sell it
but
but like that you know but it's like
it's that same kind of like question
that same like kind of tension between
like between filmmaking that's like
personal and filmmaking that's that's
like a you know commercial that is just
like we're vibrating in my head a lot
decision lace crater is about lost souls
literally and metaphorically it's a
bittersweet film about two people who
find mutual comfort and their shared
oblivion it's about small deaths the
death of a relationship the death of a
phase of our lives we move on and the
old version of us dies it's about
anxiety trying to reconcile our private
cells with our public faces and the way
that we tailor our interactions to craft
the self that we imagine others want to
see or maybe it's not about those things
at all maybe those are the themes that I
crafted of the raw material of the film
because that's what I wanted to see up
on the screen the meanings of the films
shaped by the context in which I saw
them Batman vs Superman looms so large
over this essay because it looms so very
large over the idea of this essay I want
people to see my work I want people to
be affected by what I do I want them to
take something personal away from it I
want them to engage and think it respond
and they can't do that if they don't see
it Batman vs Superman stent maybe empty
but the tentpole is so very tall that it
can be seen from miles around it becomes
a common reference point a geographic
feature a shared word the comfort of
that familiarity eases people into the
discussion even as the discussion
wanders far afield from it all creators
are beholden to the realities of process
and the pragmatics of finding an
audience film festivals like cuff are
part of that pragmatic framework I have
worried about the reach of my work as
much as the programmers of cuff worried
about the draw of their lineup as much
as the creators of the films shown
worried about finding a venue for their
work we like to think of creation as
something pure some act unsullied by any
concerns external to the creation itself
but it's not all creation is a sequence
of decisions a series of compromises and
often those answers are dictated by
externalities let's frame this another
way
Warner Brothers was so anxious about
insuring they would find an audience for
Batman vs Superman that they spent a
quarter of a billion dollars on from
the movie I spent a lot of time here
talking about context about the themes
of context in the way the context
influences creation and decision-making
and the last note of that I want to
bring this back around to is the context
in which we engage with art in a lot of
ways I find it difficult to feel animus
towards the films that I see at
festivals because the festival
environment irrevocably changes the way
that I engage with the film's it is a
completely different frame of mind when
I go into a film at a festival I am
keenly aware of the fact that I in all
likelihood know very very little about
the film itself or the background behind
it that arrangement is inherently
challenging it demands that I bring more
of myself to the film that I exert more
effort in keeping up with where the
story is going and what it's doing that
relationship alters the outcome flaws
and failings are cast in a more
charitable light as experiments that
perhaps didn't turn out quite right
conversely Batman vs Superman cannot
escape its context it cannot shake its
existence as an ever-present monolith
with a price tag higher than the GDP of
a small nation its flaws in that context
suddenly become industrial in scope and
that knowledge colors everything because
in the end we and what we bring with us
is the most important context there is